sandrine vous êtes la mère de charlie
qui est auteur d'une vidéo j'ai pas
envie de dire qui a pesé
voilà donc voilà la danse dans ce cas là
une vidéo qui a été beaucoup vu parce
qu'elle a interpellé beaucoup de gens et
elle a fait prendre conscience qu'ils
avaient beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants qui
souffrent et regardez cette vidéo fait
historique
j'essaie je vous avais connaître gamme
avère va depuis une dernière gentil
garçon qui s'appelle maintenant qu'ils
tapent tout le temps et aujourd'hui
c'est mon petit frère qui tape
j'ai dit à mon moment que j'ai envie
qu'ils rejoindre le bon goût de mourir
et on ait marre de ce petit gars y'a
tout le monde a pu tous les jours oui
alors son envie de merci d'être là bien
sûr vous êtes très ému en com
comme tout le monde autour de la table
il y avait même bernard vraiment là
alors sandrine est ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter ce qui se passe à l'école
pour chat ça s'est passé déjà 2 enfin ça
dure déjà depuis un an donc déjà l'année
dernière quand il rentre en cp
il a été victime de trois petits garçons
au départ donc je suis intervenue à
l'école j'espère qu'ils le souci parce
que baisser retrouvé par terre coup pied
dans le ventre dans le visage il a pris
vraiment beaucoup de coups mais c'est un
petit garçon qui est très gentille et
très calme alors qu'angie triquint il va
pas se plaindre en fait et du coup au
cours de l'année j'ai vu que charles il
avait des cernes sous les yeux
même s'il avait couché à 20 heures comme
d'habitude est rentré le midi mais on
travaille les à faire craquer les
chaussures abîmé il voulait pas manger
je fais pipi dessus à tout à chaque fois
pendant midi donc incertain
on s'est dit il ya quelque chose et là
je vais demander m'a dit il ya trois
élèves de ma classe qui me font ça je
suis intervenue à l'école la directrice
m'a reçue a pris les trois enfants a les
a sanctionnés
donc quelle a été la sanction alors la
sanction c'est eux ils ont fait des
dessins charlie donc j'ai les dessins
ils ont fait des dessins charlie en
montrant parce qu'il lui faisait
on va continuer à donner ça comme
finition voilà la finition et de la
seule solution la seule punition oui
est-ce qu'elle a convoqué les parents de
deux de ces oui oui
alors moi je les ai pas rencontrés j'ai
juste rencontré le papa du petit garçon
qui continue en fait c'est lui qui est
venu devant l'école enfin dans la cour
d'école le matin et danube et voulzy
quoi le papa il s'est excusé
le repas s'est excusé et il a demandé à
son petit garçon de s'excuser auprès de
charlie et ce monsieur là m'a dit je
vous donne mes coordonnées
c'est cela se reproduise vous m'appelez
n'y a pas de souci
oui mon action voilà oui c'est une bonne
réaction et donc et ça s'est reproduit
au bout de quelques temps vous l'avais
appelé j'ai appelé donc il répondait pas
j'ai envoyé un message sur poli j'ai
envoyé un message est là le lendemain le
papa et la maman m'attendais dans le
hall d'entrée avec dans le hall d'entrée
où on amène charlie d'accord et la maman
s'est mise à crier en me disant nous
avez vous eu le numéro de mon art riche
en faits n'étaient pas venus pour voir
la dispute mais moi je lui conseillais
qu'elle venait pour voiture pour essayer
d'arranger les choses donc je lui ai
bien dit à ces dames là c'est votre mari
qui m'a donné mettriez tellement que
j'ai dit aux enfants montés dans les
classes c'est bon je pars hélas la
directrice est venu un train venu nous a
pris parce que au sein d autre part en
voiture était mal on s'est retrouvés
vraiment dans le bureau à ce moment là
on arrache arrivait vraiment pas avoir
une discussion avec les parents le papa
qui disait rien du tout limite il a
baissé la tête nausées pas me parler et
la nommant qu elle elle comprenait pas
pourquoi j'avais le numéro du papa
d'accord bon c'est hors sujet complet
voilà et elle m'a dit elle me sort en
tout cas pour un enfant
certes inquiète et sapé par monfils
n'est pas fort choqué voilà alors la
directrice elle dit quoi ça puisque le
débat de ce soir
c'est l'école est elle responsable donc
la directrice de l'école elle a pris
quelle sanction est ce que l'élève qui
continuent à harceler votre fils est
toujours dans cette école oui donc il ça
n'a rien n'a changé pour lui d'accord
donc il ya eu il ya eu donc juste une
seule sanction c'est qu'il a dû faire un
dessin à charlie alors lui alors du coup
sûr les trois petits garçons 2 ont fait
des dessins et le fait que le papa est
venu présenter ses excuses
le petit n'avait pas à faire de dessin
d'accord voilà alors non mais c'est la
question que répond à la question
exactement
l'école est responsable les yeux et
franchement oui mais pourquoi l'école ne
fait rien là dessus
est ce que c'est une preuve un problème
juste de personnes c'est cette
directrice a ou est-ce que c'est propre
à tous les établissements
justement je me tourne vers soizic
perrot adjointe à la mairie de loudéac
et professeurs soizic là c'est
incroyable cette histoire ils n'ont à
tous les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent ce soir se disent mais qu'est
ce qu'elle fait quoi la directrice
c'est incroyable mais c'est incroyable
c'est inacceptable et finalement mais il
faut y répondre a aussi avec du avec du
fond il faut aussi sortir aussi de
l'excès de de la médiatisation pour
pouvoir apporter des réponses concrètes
moi je crois pas à dire que c'est tout
blanc ou c'est tout tout noir finalement
je savais qu'il ya aucun professeur que
c'est un rêve je voulais venir ce soir
ah oui aucun n'a voulu venir il ya moi
je suis ravi merci des gens comme vous
l'avez dit moi je suis pas adjoint de
ludia que celle adjointe de pontivy
c'est juste pour vous est aussi adjoint
de loudéac maintenant ses poils
bassignana qu'on fait plaisir non mais
juste pour vous dire plus sérieusement
parce que le sujet est brûlant
effectivement c'est un sujet de société
nous parle beaucoup au quotidien on est
on est confrontés à ces problèmes de
harcèlement et puis après il ya des
degrés dans le harcèlement comme vous
l'avez dit c'est une responsabilité qui
est partagé et d'abord les premiers le
rôle essentiel à jouer c'est pour les
parents premiers aussi responsable c'est
ce qu'ils vivent au quotidien avec
l'enfant qui connaissent parfaitement
leur ample mais choisit qu eux
voilà qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire à
cette directrice qui laisse sept enfants
dans l'école qui lui demande juste qu'il
demande juste aux élèves de faire un
dessin
à charlie question quelles devraient
être les vraies sanctions là dessus vous
auriez fait quoi bon personnellement ça
arrive régulièrement parce que
régulièrement donc dès qu'on a des
signalements au travail main dans la
main voilà je parle en tant qu'adjointe
à l'éducation au travail main dans la
main avec l'inspection l'inspecteur
d'académie l'éducation nationale donc
parfois aussi la gendarmerie par novès
mais oui mais toi tu es ici pâle et on
travaille à rien nous fait un
signalement demain il va faire quoi le
petit va quitter l'école c'est ça qui va
faire il va faire il va quitter l'école
le petit charlie le petit charlie bell
peut être effectivement il faut une
sanction il ya une sanction initiale
s'est pas minutes fonctionner mais il
faut et agde est à dire des faits aussi
mais madame je regarde ça l expression
qui me vient en tête c'est
non-assistance à personne en danger je
vous le dis franchement il ya un moment
faut arrêter avec lui faire faire des
dessins c'est tout n'est pas blanc tout
n'est pas noir vous cache pas que c'est
très noir quand la main mais ne s'est
pas complètement karin viard ivoire
était un peu quoi